our series earth 365 focuses on issues
that affect our planet year round one of
the most anticipated voices at the U.N
climate Summit currently underway in
Egypt doesn't belong to a politician or
a scientist it belongs to a 25 year old
Ugandan climate activist named Vanessa
nakante senior National and
environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
recently caught up with her as the world
prepared to focus attention on her home
continent of Africa
we don't need any more words we need
real action
Vanessa nakate benefits from the clarity
of Youth the 25 year old climate
activist is tired of politicians saying
a lot about the climate crisis and then
doing too little about it the climate
crisis is impacting people right now and
yet we are still you know holding
conferences we are still holding Summits
and yet people continue to suffer and so
your point is stop talking start doing
exactly
scientists warn that the impacts of
climate change are accelerating and
efforts to curb Planet warming pollution
are not nearly enough necate whose
influential activism has landed her on
the cover of Time Magazine now finds
herself in some ways representing a
continent of 1.4 billion people that is
uniquely vulnerable we've seen some of
the worst impacts of the climate crisis
you know across Africa it is
heartbreaking and frustrating because
you didn't cause this crisis but then
you are suffering the impacts Africa
accounts for the smallest share of
Planet warming greenhouse gas emissions
a fraction of what China the U.S and the
European Union emit but climate change
is punishing the African continent all
the same rising sea levels record
flooding and extreme heat waves and
drought are intensifying famine and
displacing entire communities
communities are struggling to find 4
good to it they're struggling to find
water because the entire place is dry we
talk here a lot about can we afford
electric cars is there enough wind and
solar but what you're saying is this is
much more acute life and death struggles
there are people that are suffering
severely and they don't need an electric
vehicle they need food they need water
nakate started a youth climate movement
in her native Uganda in 2019 by
protesting on the street we are
unstoppable she says she was inspired by
Swedish climate activist Greta tunberg
who waged her own climate strike when
she was just 15. what is it do you think
that young people understand about
climate change that a lot of adults
don't seem to I think young people
understand the science of climate change
and what is really happening I think
they understand the agency of the
problem
[Applause]
but it's important to know that young
people can't do this alone people say
you know the future is in your hands but
the people with the money to transform
communities they hold you know the power
to effect change in Africa we've really
had crazy floods in 2020 nakante spoke
truth to the powerful at the world
economic Forum in Davos Switzerland she
then posed for a photograph with four
other young climate activists all of
them white including Greta tunberg but
when the Associated Press released the
photo that was printed around the world
nakate was cropped out that was one of
the most you know heartbreaking moments
in my activism the world is so cruel in
an emotional 10-minute video she posted
to Twitter necate said it wasn't just
her face that was being erased does that
mean that I have no value as an African
activist or the people from Africa don't
have any value at all
one of the key things that I emphasize
during the press conference was the need
to listen to every voice so it was
heartbreaking for me to see that picture
and not see myself that it certainly
reinforced the message you were trying
to deliver in a really unfortunate way
and it really showed how those that are
on the front lines are not on the front
pages the AP later apologized and
nakante has used that experience to fuel
her fight for climate Justice and make
sure African faces and voices are seen
and heard there are always moments of
frustration when we met up at the
Brooklyn Botanical Garden she told us
she still remains hopeful the world will
make progress on combating climate
change I have to find a place of hope
because it is in that hope that I get
the strength to continue fighting in the
meantime she says the rich nations of
the world the so-called Global North
need to make good on their promise to
provide 100 billion a year to poor
countries like Uganda to help them adapt
to climate change we need to move from
promises to real action I promise
gives hope for a while
but when it's broken it brings
disappointment we need real action and
real action is possible for CBS mornings
I'm Ben Tracy in New York
well thank you Ben for introducing many
people to Vanessa I first saw on the
cover of Time Magazine but as painful
and insulting is that deliberate
decision was to cut her out of the
picture it now has drawn more attention
to her and what she's doing and it's the
order yeah and it motivated her yes yes
yes I liked what what Ben said she
benefits from the clarity of Youth and
she's over conferences and Summits now
people let's do something yeah thank you
very much